AMERICA'S CLOSER ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA.
HERE IS THE PROSPECTS OF THAT
TONIGHT FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
>> CRITICS CHARGE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS NEEDLESSLIAN TAGINIZING
THE EUROPE ON STEEL.
AND THE EUROPEAN COMMISSION
PRESIDENT SAID EACH TIME HE
THINKS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP HE'S
LOST.
AND HE SAID QUOTE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO RECONNECT
WITH RUSSIA.
I AM NOT HAPPY WITH THE
RELATIONS.
DIPLOMATS WARN OF A COUNTER
WEIGHT OF RUSSIA AND EUROPEAN
FIRMS TO EXPAND THEIR BUSINESS
THERE.
NFRANCE AND GERMANY TRYING TO
PLAY BOTH SIDES AND PLAY THE
UNITED STATES AND RUSSIA AT THE
SAME TIME AND THAT REALIZATION
THAT RUSSIA IS NOT A RELIABLE
ECONOMIC PARTNER BUT A SECURITY
THREAT TO EUROPE HAS NOT SUNK
IN.
>> Reporter: THEY SELL NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WORK IS BEGINNING
ON A PIPELINE FROM RUSSIA TO
GERMANY AND DOUBLE THE GAS
CAPACITY OVER THE BALTIC SEA.
THE ADMINISTRATION PUSHES IT TO
DO BUSINESS WITH RUSSIA.
>> THE STRATEGY WITH THE UNITED
STATES AND EUROPE TO REMIND
EUROPEAN BUSINESSES WHAT THEY
ARE DEALING WITH, WHEN THEY DEAL
WITH RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: RUSSIAN TRADE WITH
THE EU IS DOWN AFTER RUSSIA
INVADED UKRAINE AND SEIZED
CRIMEA AND MORE THAN 260 BILLION
LAST YEAR.
RUSSIAN OFFENSE AND THE
ACTIVITIES SPEAK FOR SDMEMZ MANY
BUSINESSES IN EUROPE ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
>> Reporter: THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION PRESIDENT WHILE
EUROPE WILL NEVER FORGET THE